welcome to the 2019 MTV movie and TV
Awards yes yes it's that big the 2019
MTV movie and TV Awards were full of
entertaining exciting and emotional
moments with host Zachary Levi kicking
things off most of his jokes went over
well except this one about Ray J which
set his wife off
Ray J from Love & Hip Hop is here
although I'm sure some of you are more
familiar with his work as a cameraman
the first award of the night went to
Sandra Bullock for most frightening
performance for her role in Bird box and
when I finished the film I went to my
babies and I said here mommy made this
for you and even though you can't see it
into your 21 you will know when you see
it that there isn't anything I wouldn't
do for you I was just blessed with
incredible kids and I'm an incredibly
honest mom and they know what's what but
they're also brave and they're safe and
they're happy and they get I want them
to go up to be who they're supposed to
be wanna Condor and Noah sent nao one
over our hearts and to all the boys I've
loved before their magnetic chemistry
was so good it scored them best kiss
thanks to Lana's lips can you tell us
anything about that one about the next
one no there's a new love interest best
fight went to brie Larson for her skills
in Captain Marvel
she paid tribute to her stunt doubles
Johanna Bennett and Renae moneymaker by
bringing them on stage to help accept
the award the big awards this year went
to two stars who were doing big things
on and off the screen the generation
award went to Dwayne the rock Johnson
who reflected on the early days of his
career I mean I was is half black half
Samoan six foot four 275 pound pro
wrestler
you know I was told at that time well
you got to be a certain way so I made a
choice and choice was I wasn't going to
conform to Hollywood Hollywood was gonna
conform to me and shared the advice that
helped him get where he is today it's
nice to be important but it's more
important to be nice
remember the real power is not only
being authentic but being kind and
compassionate and inclusive and work
your ass off the Trailblazer award went
to Jada Pinkett Smith her close pal
Tiffany Haddish praised her before
handing out her trophy she's never
stopped pushing boundaries she doesn't
know the meaning of the word no her red
Table Talk series it's setting the scene
but talk shows in this next century and
bringing together generations every
single person in this room is
trailblazing whether it's within or
without I feel good to be able to create
a platform that we can have these kind
of conversations that we're having I
feel really really honored and I feel
like something I'm meant to do and
perhaps the most poignant moment of the
night when surviving r.kelly won for
Best Documentary and the alleged victims
took the stage to accept the award
because of your bravery other girls and
boys and women and men are now speaking
without shame and being heard without
judgment because of your courage you
created change and you survived so thank
you